في المقابل اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه
ثلاثه من جنوده في قصف صاروخي استهدف
بلدات ومواقع في اصبع الجليل والجليل
الاعلى بالقرب من الحدود مع لبنان وافاد
مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي انفجارات وتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في محيط ثكنه هونين باصبع
الجليل وذكرت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
قاعده عسكريه في كريات ش مونا تعرضت لقصف
صاروخي ادى الى اندلاع حرائق فيها واعلنت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن اغلاق الطرق في
محيط الثكنه وبثت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
صورا قالت انها لنقل طائره مروحيه جنود
مصابين الى المستشفى بينما قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان طائراته قصفت منطقه الخيام
التي انطلقت منها صواريخ حزب الله باتجاه
كريات شمنا وفق
قوله من الجليل الاعلى مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود حسان المشهد
لديك
سلمى المشهد يشير الى تصعيد واضح على طول
هذه الجبهه الممتده من اصبع الجليل حتى
راس النقور كل هذه المنطقه تشهد توترا
واضحا لكن المنطقه التي نتواجد فيها هنا
في اصبع الجليل شهدت عده ضربات صاروخيه
اليوم
واصوات الانفجارات سواء كان عبر الضربات
الصاروخيه الاتيه من الجنوب اللبناني
باتجاه هذه المناطق لا سما المنطقه
الواقعه في محيط كريات شموه و
المواقع العسكريه القريبه منها التي
سنشاهدها هنا تشهد بشكل متواصل سماع دوي
انفجارات عبر اطلاق الصواريخ من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه هذه المنطقه وكان اخر
المواقع التي سمعنا منها دويا فيجار
ورصدنا كذلك دخانا متصاعدا جراء هذا
الانفجار كان بالقرب وفي محيط موقع هنين
العسكري وسكنه هنين الواقعه بالقرب من
الحدود مع لبنان غربي اصبع الجليل وهي
التي نشاهدها
على الشاشه وهذه المنطقه فيها عدد كبير من
المواقع العسكريه من بينها موقع المرج
وكذلك كل من بلدات مسغاف عام وكريات شموه
وكذلك ماريوت والتي تتعرض بشكل متواصل ل
الضربات الصاروخيه وكذلك ايضا نسمع دويه
انفجارات متواصله جراء اطلاق المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ل قذائفها باتجاه جنوب لبنان
قبل قليل ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قد
اصدر بيان
تحدث فيه عن واقع الهجمات التي تعرضت لها
هذه البلدات صباح هذا اليوم سواء كانت
بلده كريش مونا التي نشاهدها في هذه
الاثناء وهي التي اصيبت بصاروخ على الاقل
وهو صاروخ موجه كما قالت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي وادى ذلك الى اصابه خطيره
لجندي اسرائيلي اذاعه الجيش تحدثت عن عن
ضابط ضابط صف تحديدا في الجيش هو الذي
اصيب بهذه الجراح الخطيره لكن بيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اكتفى بال بالقول بانه جندي
اصيب بجراح خطيره ونقل الى المستشفى
وابلغت عائلته الا ان الضربه الثانيه ايضا
التي اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي حدوثها كانت في
ثكنه برانيت التي ايضا اعلن اصابه جنديين
باصابات وصفها
[موسيقى]
بالطفيفة الا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
تحدث عن ضربه صاروخيه وجهت نحو جبل الشيخ
حيث نوجد وكنا قد رصدنا ذلك ايضا خلال هذا
اليوم دون ان يتحدث عن تفاصيل هذه الضربه
وما اذا ادت الى اضرار او اصابات هذا ياتي
ايضا بالتزامن مع اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي
تنفيذه لغارات باتجاه بلده الخيام بشكل
اساسي لكننا ايضا قبل قليل رصدنا انطلاق
اربع طائرات حربيه من هنا من هذه المنطقه
من الجيل الاعلى باتجاه جنوب لبنان بشكل
متزامن شكرا لك حسام مسعود من الجليل
الاعلى